ils ont conjuré le mauvais sort la
bouteille se brise du premier coup le
géant du fret cm à cgm vient de baptiser
son tout dernier navire il l'appelle
sorte de france nous sommes très
attachés à notre développement aux
antilles et notamment à notre présence à
martinique et c'est pour ça nous avons
souhaité pour ce premier navire de 3500
vp c'est une nouvelle flotte de quatre
navires que la commande est on a
souhaité qu'il porte le nom de la de la
ville de fort de france
c est ma cgm c'est la troisième
compagnie de fret maritime au monde et
la première en france
alors pour la ministre d outre-mer le
choix de ce nom que c'est un symbole
fort est la preuve que la croissance
bleue
ce n'est pas qu'une utopie ses larges
ses 7200 emploie aujourd'hui sur le port
de la martinique
et puis c'est tout ce qui en découle
aussi c'est l'interface entre le port et
l'aéroport où s'est aussi l'interface
entre le port et la ville et c'est tout
ça qui doit être réfléchi et on est dans
un élan dynamique il faut effectivement
pouvoir continuer on l'a vu aujourd'hui
dans toutes les séquences que l'on a
fait sur la question du port ou du
transport
et bien il y avait l'ensemble de la
classe politique
l'ensemble des responsables économiques
qui étaient présents pour dire eh bien
on y va parce que c'est là qu'on a des
réponses à l'emploi à l'innovation à la
création ici en martyr
et presque tous les acteurs du monde
économique étaient effectivement
présents ce matin les élus moins
nombreux certes ont tenu à assister à ce
baptême et particulièrement le président
du conseil exécutif de la cité j'étais
président de l'expo cher régional de
martin et à ce titre toutes les
modernisations qui ont été portées au
port et à l'aéroport ont été faites par
celui qui vous parle
texen ne peut nier sa à ce qu'on oublie
de le dieu donc mon engagement à partir
de là à continuer tout naturellement l
activité tournée vers la mer ce que l'on
appelle la croissance bleue représente
12 % des emplois en martinique
un taux qui devrait augmenter dans les
prochaines années